on va faire avec vous le fil des
événements voir la chronologie des
événements parce que exactement pour
bien comprendre et dans quel ordre ça
c'est produit j'aurais aimé ça vous
montrer une carte mais bon ce que je
voudrais faire si vous montrez que on
parle d attente est au coeur de paris
eh ben c'est quand même commencé au nord
de paris dans la banlieue parisienne de
saint denis stade de france vous voyez
les images on a tant entendu trois
déflagrations vers lee 9
21h15 21h20 et c'est là que ça a
commencé il ya quatre personnes qui sont
mortes la trois assaillants
une victime et après les événements sont
descendus plus dans le sud plusieurs le
coeur de paris et l'a ensuite ça
s'accélère en quelque sorte en très peu
de temps et c'est de plus en plus
sanglant les attaques se multiplient en
plein coeur de paris
quelques minutes à peine ce qui se passe
au stade de france ça va se produire
justement les vraiment au coeur de paris
d'abord on ne sait pas dans quel ordre
exactement mais on sait que sur la rue
fontaine de roi situé juste à côté de
république cinq morts au moins
bichat dose victime rue de charonne 19
morts boulevard voltaire
une seule personne est morte on pense
que c'est un des assaillants mais
vraiment le coeur de tout ce qui va se
passer c'est au bataclan une salle de
spectacle plein à craquer des
assaillants vont entrer tiré sur la
foule
joujou je vous propose de regarder des
images qui ont été filmée par un
journaliste qui coïncidence habite
derrière le barde bataclan pour bien
comprendre l'ambiance du ce ou plutôt la
situation dans laquelle les gens se
retrouvaient pour fuir l'endroit on
écoute
ça va
ce gaz russe
[Musique]
vous a écouté aidez-moi aidez-moi je
suis sous peu que c'est un sport qu'ils
ont entendu une journaliste qui comprend
pas ce qui se passe lors ce qu'ils
veulent comprendre une voix décembre
ouvrir sa porte pour donner un refuge
aux gens qu'ils aux gens qui tentent de
fuir un endroit
le journaliste sera atteint d'une balle
et il va être hospitalisés avec les
nombreux blessés du bataillon patatras
ça va prendre quand même quelques heures
avant que les polices les policiers
décident de mener l'assaut
notre collègue jean françois bélanger
était sur place pendant l'assaut voici
ce que ça donne oui oui écouter et à
écouter écouter écouter on entend des
déflagrations actuellement c'est plus
que des coups de feu c'est des grenades
assourdissantes probablement un assaut
qui a lancé sur le théâtre
ou alors ou alors tu est un acte commis
par les gens de ce toit est à écouter
ça se passe de ce côté ci se passe de ce
côté-ci regarder les policiers sont
beaucoup plus nerveux tout à coup donc
les gens les policiers vont entrer dans
la place vont pouvoir sauver la vie à de
nombreuses personnes
mais c'est vraiment là qu'on va
découvrir l'ampleur de la tragédie on
parle d'au moins 70 morts près d'une
centaine de gens qui vont avoir perdu la
vie au bataclan en tout et les
assaillants ont dit qu'ils sont tous
morts on parle de huit assaillants dont
sept se sont enlevé la vie ils étaient
des kamikazes
pour les détails sur leur identité qui
va revendiquer tous ces événements qui
se sont déroulés sur quelques heures et
ben ça ça reste à voir
c'est encore en évolution il faudra
attendre il faudra être patient les
enquêtes je poursuive
elles en sont à un stade préliminaire il
faut le dire une chose est sûre leur but
est clair tuer et tuer le plus de
personnes possible merci beaucoup pascal